*The Legend of the Frick*
Today, I'm gonna tell you about the Legend of the Frick.
The Frickening
It's a tale of a frick man.
It's a tale of...
*breathing* WHAT THE FRICK
...fantasizes
THIS JUST CAN'T EVER-
That can never be quenched.
I'm talking of course, about the frick man himself
Sammy, sonic fan.
Sammy, the frick.
*i can't caption this*
*The Frickening*
WHAT THE FRICK ARE YOU GUYS DOING?!
ASKING FOR ALL THIS FRICKING GARBAGE?
Sammy, I'm sure a lot of you have seen before.
But, do we really know the story about Sammy?
And what happened to Sammy?
I say "what the frick"
Let's jump into it
*child screaming*
Sammy's first video began in April, 2013.
He uploaded his first review video.
A Super Mario Bros Wii Review
And let me fricking tell you...
...it's something to behold.
Sammy (Frick Kid): OK
Today I'm gonna review this Mario Bros Wii for Nintendo Wii
Okay this game was released back in 2009...
Pewds: It all seems so innocent
until...
...until it took a very dark turn.
Sammy (Frick Kid): okay..
so let's get to the most important aspect: creativity
WHAT THE HECK NINTENDO?!
Pewds: Aah! *giggling like a 5 year old*
The microphone! How did he attain such amazing audio quality?
Sammy (Frick Kid): WHAT THE HECK NINTENDO!?
Pewds: *chuckles* It's absolutely perfect!
Sammy (Frick Kid): Now for the controls.
WHAT THE HECK NINTENDO!?
MOTION CONTROLS
Did he just say "heck" and not "frick"? What the frick?
I could listen to this kid scream "what the frick" in my ears
in a thousand decibels all day long
I love it, I live for it.